foreign
[Music]
Once Upon a Time Steve Jobs himself
looked up to HP but today no one is even
looking at HP the search interests
surrounding the company has fallen by
over 60 percent throughout the past 20
years and the situation at the company
is only worse HP has been embroiled in
multiple lawsuits regarding missed
payments bribery and the breaches of
contract they tried to expand out of
their main business and enter the
rapidly growing Enterprise software
industry only to massively overpay for
an acquisition and end up writing off
8.8 billion dollars pretty soon HP had
to shift their focus from trying to
expand into new Industries to just
trying to survive they would split up HP
into two different companies a personal
computer business and a printer business
but this Niche down Focus didn't help
much HP would be forced to do layoffs
alone left right up and down eliminating
thousands of jobs with each and every
cut back in 2010 HP had as many as 350
000 employees but by 2021 this number
would decrease to 51 000 in the original
company and 60 000 in the spin-off in
other words HP has shed at nearly a
quarter million employees you would
think that this massive cut and head
count would strengthen at hp's
financials but in reality they've only
been getting weaker and weaker things
have gotten so bad that both companies
have a non-negligible chance of going
bankrupt HP Inc currently has a
bankruptcy probability of 38 and the HP
Enterprise has a bankruptcy probability
of 44 for perspective spawn companies
like apple tend to have bankruptcy
probabilities in the low single digits
so HP is definitely on their last legs
today but wasn't always like this for
over half a century hpe was an
Electronics Juggernaut and virtually
everyone knew the iconic logo HP wasn't
just popular amongst the public either
they were and still are absolute Legends
in Silicon Valley having been one of the
first tech companies to be founded in
the valley so here's the story of how HP
went from being the father of Silicon
Valley to being consumed by the same
companies that they had inspired
foreign
taking a look back the story of HP dates
back over a hundred years to a man named
it William Readington Hewlett or Bill
Hewlett bill was born on May 20th 1913
and right before the start of World War
one but fortunately Bill's family
wouldn't be affected too much by the war
as his father was a respected medical
professor at the University of Michigan
in fact his father would actually get a
promotion during the war to Stanford
University resulting in the family
relocating the modern day Silicon Valley
unlike many Silicon Valley Founders
today bill would end up following in his
father's academic footsteps and become a
highly educated man first he would
attend Stanford University where he
received a bachelor's in Engineering in
1934. he would follow this up with a
masters in electrical engineering from
MIT in 1936 before returning to Stanford
to get a postmaster's electrical
engineering degree in 1939 little to say
Bill spent the most of his 20s in
college this first class education not
only give Bill a strong understanding of
engineering but it also led him to
crossing paths with this future lifelong
friend David Packard like Bill David was
born on the onset of World War One on
September 7th 1912 in Pueblo Colorado
David also came from a Wella family as
his father was a respected attorney but
unlike Bill David wasn't as drawn
towards engineering from a young age
rather one of his biggest passions was
Sports and he would spend much of his
undergraduate years at Stanford playing
basketball and football but he didn't
pursue these interests after college and
he would settle for something much less
daring a job at the General Electric in
New York he didn't stay here for long
though as he would return to Stanford to
get a masters in electrical engineering
little did she know this educational
trip would end up becoming a permanent
day you see it David and the bill would
start working on small electronics
projects in a rented garage using 538
dollars they built things like frequency
oscillators distortion analyzers and
audio signal generators about a year
after they started working on these side
projects Bill and David would decide to
make the partnership official fun fact
the name of this new company was decided
by a coin flip if David had won the coin
flip the company's name would have been
pH and it's probably a good thing that
bill won as pH would have given a lot of
people nightmares about high school
chemistry now that HP was official Bill
and David had to focus on projects that
were actually commercially viable which
led them to audio oscillators one of the
biggest shortfalls of 1930s oscillators
was that they weren't all that stable
Bill and David would fix this shortfall
by incorporating an incandescent light
bulb into their oscillator which acted
as a resistor stabilizing the output HP
would dub this product the 200a and that
Not only was it more stable than the
competition but it was way cheaper
coming in at 89 dollars and at 40 cents
most of the oscillators on the market
were selling for well over two hundred
dollars this value quickly caught the
attention of Bud Hawkins who was the
chief sound engineer at Walt Disney
Studios but what agreed to buy eight of
these oscillators for Disney's upcoming
film Fantasia and that this would go
down as hp's first major order it was by
no means their last though by the end of
their first year in business HP would
end up pulling 5 369 worth of Revenue
and 1 563 dollars worth of profit this
is the same as 115 000 worth of Revenue
and at 33 000 worth of profit today and
with that HP was in business
moving into the 1940s HP would start
producing equipment for the war and this
would prove to be extremely lucrative
they continued selling their classic
products like wave analyzers and audio
signal generators but they would also
produce a few more specific products
like contrabrator technology and
artillery shell proximity fuses by the
end of the war HP would employ 200
people and the company was large enough
to be incorporated as a full-on company
as opposed to just a partnership
business was a booming and sales would
reach 5.5 million dollars by 1951 the
same as 63 million dollars today and the
funny part was that HPA had yet to even
enter any of the businesses that they're
known for today but this would all
change due to eight individuals at the
time semiconductors weren't an actual
business concept it was just something
that engineering professors and PhD
students doubled with such was the case
with Professor William Shockley and
eight of his PhD graduates truth be told
these eight graduates hated Professor
Shockley and in 1957 they would make the
Bold decision to ditch Shockley and to
create their own company very childhood
semiconductor these eight are now known
as the traitor S8 and they're basically
the pioneers of the semiconductor
industry they would end up creating
dozens of smaller chip companies from
Fairchild including both Intel and AMD
HP was watching all of this unfolded
firsthand and they wanted a piece of the
action so they would begin investing
heavily into semiconductors themselves
throughout the 1960s they partnered with
the Sony and yokogava electric but this
actually turned out to be a big mistake
it turned out that Outsourcing chips to
Japan was actually more expensive than
producing in America this blunder
consistently made them one step behind
Fairchild and eventually Intel but HP
continued persisting and they would
eventually enter the Computing space in
1966 with the HP 2100 and the HP 1000
these were mini computers that were
primarily used for business applications
and HP were defined quite a bit success
in this area but for some reason they
didn't want to expand from outside this
area in fact they didn't even want to
expand it to the personal computer space
and this wasn't just an oversight they
were consciously avoiding the PC space
Steve Wozniak was actually an HP
employee at the time and he pitched
their PC idea to HP on five different
occasions it wasn't until he was turned
down all five times that he would
finally agree to start apple with Steve
Jobs that's truly quite a shame that HP
turned down Wozniak but then again we
wouldn't have apple if it wasn't further
stubbornness ironically though HP would
eventually end up entering the PC space
themselves in 1980 with the HP 85 which
was designed to be a direct competitor
to IBM a couple of years later HP would
introduce a lineup of inkjet and Laser
Printers along with a lineup of scanners
as well and this leads us to the HP that
we're all familiar with today but unlike
today HP wasn't doing bad in fact they
were killing it they would register the
domain hp.com in 1986 which was the
ninth domain to ever be registered and
one year later the garage that bill and
David used to start HP would be
officially designated as a historical
landmark moving into the 1990s HP would
make Acquisitions left and right
becoming a householder computer brand
and grow to be one of the largest
companies in the world period so what
happened
foreign
can't be explained by any singular
reason rather it was just accumulation
of several smaller factors and the
trends starting with the commoditization
of PCS back in the day the brand of a
computer carried significant weight
people wanted a Dell or an HPA or an
apple but the only company that has been
able to hold on to this differentiation
is Apple nowadays you go apple or you go
Windows if you go Windows much of your
purchasing decision is just based on
which company is offering the best value
at the time as opposed to the brand so
HP didn't have a very good shot in the
face of lower cost Alternatives from
companies like Acer nonetheless HP tried
to compete with selected their profit
margins being put all down to the low
single digit figures they'll also faced
a similar crisis but they addressed the
situation in a completely different
manner Michael Dell came out of
retirement took the company public and
they basically quit the tumor space they
pulled a Microsoft and switched over to
offering infrastructure Solutions and
the cloud computing and these are the
sectors that are really driving Dell
today their consumer business is more
for brand recognition purposes than
actually making money HP on the other
hand continued pursuing the PC and the
printer space year after year HP did try
to enter their Cloud space themselves
but no serious company would even
consider them as a solution HP also
flirted with the idea of entering the
mobile space in July of 2011 HP launched
their touchpad but this was such a
massive flop that they would discontinue
their product less than two months later
I don't think you'd be surprised to hear
that HP didn't look back at the mobile
space but likely their biggest blunder
was their attempt to take over autonomy
Corporation autonomy was an Enterprise
software company and HP hoped that this
is exactly what they needed to break
into the Enterprise Market they spent a
10.3 billion dollars to buy a majority
stake in the company but truth be told
the HP branded just dragged down
autonomy and HP would end up writing off
autonomy as an 8.8 billion loss not long
after at this point hp's Core Business
was declining and that all of their new
Endeavors were not only failing but
burning massive amounts of money so HP
had no choice but to Pivot from trying
to Pivot to just trying to survive this
led to loads of layoffs spinning off
various businesses into even splitting
the company leading us to where we are
today
foreign
on the surface it looks like HP put a
lot of effort into trying to Pivot but
the truth is that all of their efforts
were just Band-Aids for the underlying
fundamental problem which was that the
American tech industry had moved away
from Hardware the new industries were
data collection cloud computing
artificial intelligence machine learning
mobile development and the internet
there's a reason that Google sells all
of their hardware for no profit or for a
loss the money is not in the hardware
it's in the software this is true for
even apple and that's why they've been
placing such a large emphasis on their
surfaces meanwhile HP has been beating a
dead horse for decades now and it's been
consistently looking worse and worse for
them this isn't to say that they're
gonna go bankrupt tomorrow but at this
point their future isn't looking too
bright unless they have a true
Revolution and that's how HP became
irrelevant do you think HP could have
played their cards better comment that
down below also drop a like if you hope
that HP rests in peace and of course
consider checking out our Discord
Community to just future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then I'm sorry and I'll see you guys on
the next one
[Music]
foreign